коли президент Зеленський сказав ви
будете отримувати тридцятку всі до кінця
війни ві всіх хто в погонах потім війна
не закінчилася а тридцятка закінчилася І
це просто неповага і він навіть не
знайшов собі сили вийти і сказати ви
знаєте хлопці я так думав я так хотів
але ну щось мені заважає от не можу я от
не витягує держава не вистачає грошей не
вистачає сил ну вийди і скажи це людям в
обличчя і ми не можемо платити а хочете
я вам скажу чому він не виходить і не
робить цього тому що одразу люди
спитають а як же так Тото виходить
значить на нас немає коштів а на
барабани на серіали на яйця по 17 грн є
Та за таке треба оце по 17 грн відривати
тим хто таке робить